- Do you know that I
do not play the lottery
'cause I'm scared to win?
- [Cameraman] You're scared to win?
- I do not play the lottery
because I'm scared to win
because then everybody
will say that it was
the lottery ticket that enabled me to do
the things I plan on doing
in the next 50 years.
- [DRock] Easy money scares you, then.
- 100%
- Wow.
- Yup.
- I think that's
the first time I've heard you say that.
- It's the first time
I've said it out loud.
(booming)
(yelling)
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(revved up music)
(cheering)
(rewinding)
(mellow music)
- [Assistant] What's the question, Beej?
- [Beej] So Gary Vee, what's
the difference between
a successful creative and a
successful businessperson?
- The way the person decides to judge it.
- Interesting.
- You know, like,
it's just the way you
decide to judge it, right?
Like, I wanna be the most
successful businessperson
of all time but I've
decided to judge that as
impacting other people,
not making the most money.
You know, like, what's
a successful creative?
Everybody in the world seeing it
or 10,000 people being changed by it?
It just comes down to
how you judge it, bro.
- [Beej] Yeah, no, I got my own theory but
I wanna hear yours 'cause, like--
- That's mine.
- Yeah.
- It's cool.
- Appreciate it, man.
- Take care of yourself. I
love your hair, by the way.
Can I ask a question?
- Yeah.
- Been thinkin' about this
about you for a minute.
Like, every time I see
you at the Knick games,
I'm always like, I can't,
I love business so much,
it's all I think about, kind of.
I think you're a really unique
dude from, on a, on some,
like, I think your ranking, ranking,
like, arbitrary ranking in
culture, is really high.
- Oh, wow.
- Like, when I say that,
does that make sense to you?
Like, I think people fuck
with you way bigger than
the way you're playing right
now and so when I watch it--
- I tell him that.
- No, they, my brother,
he tells, a lotta people tell me that.
I just, I just feel like
I'm just like, normal.
- By the way, by the way, that's fine.
I'm talkin' about, like,
thoughtfully thinking about,
like the actual opportunities
that you could have.
I have no idea what
the fuck you care about
but I can tell you one thing: there,
what I'm good at is, like, FILA.
FILA's our client at VaynerMedia.
Like, we rebooted that brand.
Like, that brand meant
nothing three years ago.
And I understood that it
had more equity in it.
Like, that's what, that's my whole jam.
My whole jam is, like, why was
Marvel comic books bankrupt
but then if you looked at
it at a different angle,
it was a trillion dollar movie franchise?
Why was FILA something that
nobody gave a fuck about
but if you made dad shoes for
girls, it fuckin' took over?
Why was Champion, Champion
four years ago was Walmart.
- Yeah, it was Walmart.
- Yeah, it was.
No, no, for real, now--
- For 49 year old white dudes.
So, on that kick, on some real shit,
Nate, on some real shit,
call it swag, call it culture,
people fuckin' like you, bro.
And, like, you represent something.
If you, back to the
Players' Tribune thing, if,
I don't know what it is, I'd
be lyin' if I said I did,
but if you do one smart
thing that is the right look
and enough people see it, all the shit
that I'm talkin' about right now
that you're actually sitting on, opens up.
- Right.
- You know what?
Actually, lemme, lemme throw
somethin' crazy at you.
This a real big compliment.
Marky Mark was Marky Mark but
Mark Wahlberg was an icon.
The Rock was The Rock,
everybody loved The Rock.
- Right.
- He was a huge wrestler.
Even people that don't watch wrestling
knew who the fuck he was.
Dwayne Johnson is a
totally different dude.
- Right.
- Like, The Fresh Prince of,
you guys are youngsters,
The Fresh Prince of Bel,
like, The Fresh Prince, when I was a kid,
was a fuckin' dope-ass rapper,
but Will Smith became an icon.
I swear to God, that's how I see you.
- Shit, I mean, I don't
even see myself like that.
Honestly, bro.
- By the way,
I know you don't because if you did,
you'd be doing different shit.
I understand that you don't,
that's why I'm bringing it up.
Lemme give you, this a make pretend
of, like, how I'm thinking.
If you were, like, the face of, like,
the breakout iPhone one-on-one game.
Like, John Madden, this is a good example,
John fuckin Madden, like,
had a nice sports career
callin' football and then some
small fuckin' gaming company
came to him when video
games were different--
- Tecmo Bowl.
- Yeah, Tecmo Bowl.
- No, not Tecmo Bowl,
John Madden's Football.
Different company, EA,
Tecmo Bowl was the game.
That was the game, just like NBA Live
used to be a game and now it's 2K.
Tecmo Bowl was the game
and this little company
called EA came to him and said,
"We're doing a football game.
Do you wanna be the face
of it?" He said, "Sure."
Basically, that singular decision
changed John Madden's life
financially, in the leverage he had,
and all the things, who
knows what he did with it?
You know, with the way mobile
games work and shit like that,
like, if you were the, if it was, like,
Nate Robinson's One-on-One
and that became the Fortnite,
that would be the domino that then
would open up everything else.
- I see what you're sayin'.
- You understand?
- Yes, sir.
- You need to,
and by the way, the fuckin'
Players Tribune thing,
The Big Three, in a little
way, that's flirting with it.
But you said the most important thing,
you said, "I don't even
see myself that way."
I know that because
those are the decisions
you're making versus
what I would be doing,
which is making a lot more contact.
Like, if I were you, I'd
probably go on Instagram live
for an hour every day of my life
and just fuckin' talk to people.
- Aight.
- Like,
I want you to have the leverage.
Ice Cube has the leverage.
- Right.
- Derek Jeter has the leverage.
But you have more actual end consumer
natural shit in you than both of them.
I really believe that.
I'm being dead fuckin' serious with you.
- [Nate] I can't wait to
see, like, you get me excited
just thinkin' about this shit now.
Even more so.
- It's real.
- I mean because, like, for
me, bein' a father, man,
there's so many things
that I'm thinkin' about
in tryna raise my kids the
right way and, you know,
they want so many different things
and wanna do so many different things,
they have so many different personalities.
So it's like, managin'
all that, still goin' out
workin' hard, still
goin' out doin' things.
So it's like, tryna micro-manage your life
but yet, still tryna live.
It's difficult as fuck.
- You know what the big, you know what
the biggest problem is for you and I,
is when people grow up with
nothing and they have kids,
they wanna give their kids too much.
- Facts.
- The number one thing
you can do for your kids is say no.
You know how you secretly
think in your head
how soft they are compared to you?
- Fuck yes, ain't no secretly.
It ain't no fuckin' secretly, hell yeah.
- That's next time, bro.
- We were outta there, fuck that.
Yeah, hell yeah, that's the real thing.
- That's the number one
thing you do for your kids.
I'm tellin' my kids
already, like, 13's comin'.
And 13 you're gonna go from
real rich to real poor.
I'm like, I'm not buyin' you shit.
- Ha, that's funny as hell.
- And honestly, honestly?
It's gonna be the thing
that makes them happy.
Because when you're on
the payroll and you're 23,
it's over, it's over.
All right.
- All right, man.
Thank you, man, thanks
for takin' the time.
Thanks for havin' me, bro.
- You got it, bro.
Lemme take a photo, let's take a photo.
- Of course.
- What's been goin' down?
- So, I mean, I been, like,
in between, like, workin'
and stuff, like a regular job and kinda,
like, doin' music, and
I didn't know, like,
if I should just, I
feel like I should just
stick to the music and just grind it out.
- Bro, you should live
as shitty as possible
and do the music because you
don't wanna have regret later.
You can always get a shitty job.
What job?
- She's revvin' around too.
- I saw, I saw it.
- Um, I been, like,
doin' some painting.
- Good.
You could always paint, you could always
work at fuckin' Starbucks, you could
always get a job at VaynerMedia.
You need to fuckin' see through the music,
but what you need to know
is when you're doin' that,
you're signing up for eatin' shit.
Like that, those Pumas need
to go into studio time.
- Yeah.
- I'm being serious, bro.
Like, if you're gonna see it through,
you gotta fuckin' hock 'em in.
Like, you can't be here
right now. I'm bein' serious.
Like, I know, like, like, you know,
it's good networking
and I get it, but like,
(smacking)
you gotta make the music.
'Cause music's amazing now.
Your one song away, you're
one SoundCloud moment away.
That's just real life.
(mellow music)
- Good, I'm workin' with Justin,
I have a bunch of stuff for you.
My artist that I manage made this for you.
- Holy shit, this is remarkable,
this is fuckin' fresh.
- So Bear Walker designed this for you.
- Dude, this is amazing, thank you.
- We love your shoes and--
- Yo, how,
can you guys ship this?
Like, if you ship it, I'll
actually give it some real love.
- Oh, 100%.
- But I don't wanna,
I don't wanna, like, take
it and not take it and--
- Yeah, no, it's perfect on the wall, man.
- That's why I'm saying.
Like, ship that to my office,
I'll rock it.
- Yeah, 100%, absolutely.
Can we get a pic real quick?
- Yeah, of course.
Great.
- So let's
go ahead and move on with that, right,
like you continue to
level up, and I see this.
You've got, again, the
sneakers, tops, WineText,
like, I could go on and on.
It seems to me that every
time I go on social media,
it's like Gary's showin'
up with something, right?
So, is the come up
easier than the level up?
- They're the same game, for me.
And I think for some people, the come up's
easier and the level up's harder.
For other people, it's the reverse.
For me, you know what?
It's gonna be a fun recall.
The same guy who works the room with
the same level of
humility and deep passion
to meet people and help
them, and help himself if,
serendipitously, he stumbles
into an opportunity,
who loves to cosign and watch people shine
and, like, why not, who likes
to add to that, you know,
is the same guy today that
he was seven years ago.
And that's the same with
me with WineText, tops,
like, I'm pretty much
navigating the same exact
business blueprint that got me here
and I'm a more mature version,
I'm, in the subtleties,
much better than I used
to be, but at its core.
You know, a lotta times
you hear the saying,
what got you here is what
you need to double down on.
And then you hear
contradictions like you gotta
change up now that
you're at the next level.
I think people make those things absolute.
Here's how I see it: I'm tripling down
on what got me here but
I'm maturing and evolving
around the edges and
changing certain things.
More mature, more thoughtful,
not making the same mistakes.
And, you know, experienced Gary
should be better than rookie Gary.
You know, where you end
up in your, you know,
your career is going to be
predicated on many things
and talent is one of them.
Your ambition is another. Circumstance.
You know, all of us, if we
have a tragic event, check out.
Like, there's a million
variables in life but
take away luck, like, you know.
Do you know that I do not play the lottery
'cause I'm scared to win?
- [Cameraman] You're scared to win?
- I do not play the lottery because
I'm scared to win because
then everybody will say
that it was the lottery
ticket that enabled me to do
the things I'm planning on
doing in the next 50 years.
- [Interviewer] Do you remember our talk
that we had in Denver at the museum?
- In Denver.
- Digital Summit.
It was a little, shitty green room.
- Yes.
- Like, a little room--
- Yes, yup.
- That was
the moment that changed my life.
Like, that put everything into motion.
And I left that day feeling so rejected.
- Yup.
- And just felt like a, like--
- I remember.
- I just got
turned down, dude, it's like--
- I get it.
- I just got turned down for
a dream job type scenario.
And I went home and looked
myself in the mirror
and I was like, "This guy's right.
"This guy's so fuckin' right."
- Listen, there is a small
but I'm getting big enough
large percentage of
people who don't like me.
And it's because of that thing.
I don't wanna call people
fake entrepreneurs.
I don't wanna say that
they're on daddy's money.
they're delusional or lost
or have the wrong marketing strategy.
That's not fun for me,
I hate being disliked.
I'm a tough guy on camera and on stage
but you see how I act in real life.
I'll spend 20 minutes to let somebody,
the reason that it takes
me forever to network
is it takes me seven minutes
to let them down kindly.
There is no, you know.
But I cared to help you.
Like, it's what I did in
Toronto the other day.
- Right.
- 'Cause I'm watchin'.
I'm like, "Ooh, if you can
tweak it even a little."
- Right.
- And you have,
which is why so much good is happening.
You know, the end, you know, like--
- It's called marketing.
- Hunger is
a really interesting thing, you know?
Hunger is an interesting thing
because when you're hungry,
when you get an opportunity,
you tend to over-gorge.
- When I think back, it's like--
- Real quick on this.
- Yeah.
- It's a really important
analogy that I've never really,
I've thought about but
I've never said out loud.
When you're hungry and you
get to a buffet, you throw up.
And so, when, when people
are hungry for success
and they get in front
of me or anybody else
or an opportunity, they overeat.
- Truth.
- I know.
- It's facts.
- And I know you get it.
I do get it.
- And I think
that you're eating a
couple less plates now
at your at bats, and that's
why things are happening.
- Thanks bro.
- Yeah, man.
- I appreciate that, man.
- It's true.
It's true, bro.
- I love you, dude.
- I love you back.
- Can I have a moment?
- Yeah.
- I'm off to sample the wines.
(laughing)
But in 2014, that's
when I found you, Gary.
2015, I wanted to get a tattoo of you
and then whenever I met you,
I was gonna show you that
tattoo, you'd be like,
"What the fuck is wrong witchu?"
- That's a good question.
- Do you have it?
- [DRock] Are you getting emotional, bro?
- No, I just, whenever I see you, Gary,
I don't say anything, you know?
That's the sorta respect that I have is
don't say anything to
you, just say hi, hello.
I've met you a couple
times, showed you Roland--
- Yep, yep.
- Over there, I just,
I just don't wanna go off
the whole way the whole time.
But at the end of the
day, man, you were kinda
like the father I never had, low key.
Straight up.
- That shit's crazy, man.
- Yeah, I did.
- Thank you, bro.
- It was real shit.
- That's really, like--
- You really changed the whole aspect--
- It's so crazy to be at
this point in my life where,
like, now I've put
enough on film and audio
and wax and whatever you wanna call it,
that some of this shit is
startin' to happen already,
like, these conversations
are happening already.
And I'm like, man, I'm 43.
- Just startin'.
- Like, yeah.
And I'm late as fuck for here.
You're not comin' to this, are you DRock?
- No.
- Okay.
(dramatic music)